putting us live now is Vice President
Mike Pence mr. vice president I know you
busy I we do appreciate you taking the
time to be with us and update us first I
want you to comment look what's
happening in the Senate John you know
they're they want to put more
restrictions at this time on the airline
industry and they want to help unions
and let's see what else are they doing
here oh oh they want let's see
wind and solar tax credits now it's
about the new Green Deal instead of
helping families people American
citizens small business everybody that's
struggling you kidding me well Sean what
I what I can tell you is that it it is
time for Democrats in the Senate and in
the House of Representatives to step up
reach an agreement and pass the Care Act
the president's made it clear from early
on as I made clear to governor's today
in our latest conference call where
we're working with Republican and
Democrat governors across the country
you saw the decisive action President
Trump took yesterday with major disaster
declarations in New York California
Washington we're building field
hospitals where we're moving out Navy
hospital ships I mean we are working
seamlessly with governors across the
country and up to this point on the
first two bills the Congress passed we
saw a great spirit of bipartisanship and
as the president said tonight at the
briefing we're still hopeful maybe
before the day is out tomorrow that that
will see Democrats come together with
Republicans and pass a bill that will
provide immediate financial assistance
and the the average family of four will
receive a direct payment of $3,000 to
help them weather the storm
there'll be payroll support for small
businesses around America to be able to
carry their payroll even while their
businesses have been closed by the
scourge of the coronavirus there'll be
the kind of resources to support the
major industries like Airlines and
hotels that have been so deeply impacted
through no fault of their own because of
the coronavirus and and the proper
measures
that day and every American are taking
but it really it really is a moment
where where the American people
the American people want to see the
Congress come together and I I spoke to
a member of Democrat leadership tonight
on my way home Mike my hope I think the
president's hope is that we'll work out
the final details we'll get this thing
on the floor will speed relief to the
American people and the bill will stay
focused right where it should be and
that is on on helping working Americans
families businesses across this country
weather the storm of the coronavirus mr.
vice president I'm holding up a letter
and I'm gonna read from it in a second
from a doctor than New York area and if
I may read from it he has now worked
with his his associates and he has a
regimen hydroxychloroquine 200
milligrams twice a day five days as it
throw myosin 500 milligrams once a day
five days think sulfate 220 milligrams
once a day for five days this is what he
has seen him and his team have now
treated approximately 350 patients and
Kairos Joel was an area of New York that
was hit particularly hard and another
150 patients in other New York areas his
results we have had zero deaths zero
hospitalizations zero intubation zero we
have a French study we have news out of
China Israel is donating six million
doses of hydroxychloroquine let me ask
you sir
I don't think I've ever seen anything
more hopeful since this thing started
as a treatment and we're at the first
stage of a vaccine according to doctor
pouchy who I admire a lot your thoughts
well what what what we see in some of
those anecdotal studies we're going to
put to the test you know the president
has been working we've been working with
companies across the country chloroquine
is a perfectly legal drug and at the
president's direction
the FDA is is is has completed and is
completing what's called off-label use
approval Sean so that doctors can
prescribe what is an anti-malaria drug
to deal with coronavirus I've read the
same things you've read about [ __ ]
combining those with other antibiotics
but we're we're gonna work very closely
with dr. pouchy with our team on the
ground and as as we make the chloroquine
available for Americans and other
medications we're gonna study it we're
gonna figure it out but that's not going
to get in the way of making it available
doctors will be able to prescribe it and
and based upon of the studies you're
citing and anecdotal evidence that it
appears in in in many cases that it
brings real relief and I have to tell
you the president just has a strong
feeling about it you know him well he
isn't he is he's an optimist and we
remain hopeful and but the one thing
that's been clear to me since the
president tapped me to lead the White
House coronavirus Task Force is is the
President of the United States is
absolutely committed not just to using
the full resources of the federal
government not just bringing together a
partnership with state governments a
partnership with the private sector and
calling on every American to do their
part but we are literally leaving no
stone unturned to address this crisis
and bring relief to Americans we sat
down about two weeks ago with all the
top pharmaceutical companies not just in
America Sean but in the world and they
formed a consortium at the table in the
Cabinet Room to begin immediately
working on on a vaccine which are our
FDA managed to start clinical trials in
record time now it's going to be a year
and a half before vaccine is available
but those same pharmaceuticals are
working on what are called therapeutics
which we may have out by a little bit
later this spring that will bring relief
to people you heard dr. Deb
Berks tonight at the briefing talking
about a whole range of new therapies and
in new tests that we just approved
including the new nasal swab test
that'll be soon available across the
country I mean I have to tell you that
the the energy and the creativity that
this president has been demanding from
every corner of this country is is is
reflected in our efforts about the
chloroquine it's reflected in in our
ongoing effort to make sure that that we
bring the full full weight of of America
to bear on the coronavirus last question
mr. vice president and I your staff is
gonna kill me because I'm keeping you
over time I apologize to them in advance
last question you are literally we're
watching the rewriting of history right
before our eyes everything that you and
the president are doing here from the
travel ban ten days after the first
known case in America and the quarantine
telemedicine I believe will be the
future for sure public-private
partnerships we never had that we never
had drive-up testing you announced today
that we'll have at home testing soon and
then getting rid of these FDA
regulations which otherwise it would
have taken two years sir two to get done
and what would the Democrats do when
they were in an impeachment trial and
Joe Biden was saying that Donald Trump
is xenophobic hysterical and a fear
mongerer Shawn there is no question that
if President Trump had not suspended all
travel from China before the month of
January was out we would be in a very
different place than we are today if he
hadn't issued travel advisories and
begun to screen every passenger from
every airport into the United States
from Italy in South Korea
the same is true suspending travel from
Europe the UK to Ireland I mean our
health experts have told me again and
again at our task force meetings that
it's been the president's willingness to
take those decisive actions that has
given us time to stand up
this whole of government approach in
full partnership with all the states
across this country and to your point in
full partnership with the private sector
I mean that public-private partnership
one week ago with the total number of
tests that had been reported back to the
CDC was fifty-three thousand seven days
later Sean we are at three hundred and
thirteen thousand tests that have been
done completed and the numbers actually
much larger than that because that
doesn't include more than 15,000
hospitals and labs that's all a result
of that public and private partnership
and can I just brag on American business
for just a minute yes sir you know the
the president he he invoked the defense
production Act which gives the president
the authority to mandate production
during times of national crisis and the
defense of the nation in fact today when
the president signed the executive order
regard giving the Justice Department
authority to thoroughly prosecute people
engaged in price gouging and hoarding
that came from the defense production
act but we've been asked several times
about whether the president will invoke
this will he mandate businesses but the
truth is and this just makes me smile
makes me proud as an American every
business we have asked to step up and do
their part has said yes no one has said
no yet I mean we've seen again 3m today
delivered five hundred thousand
respirator masks to New York and Seattle
Facebook just donated from their reserve
more than three-quarters of a million
mass to health care workers an Heiser
Bush is switching some of their
manufacturing and distributing networks
to produce large amounts of hand
sanitizer I mean Americans are rising to
the challenge they're embracing the 15
days to slow the spread they know that
it's about protecting the most
vulnerable among us but American
business is also rising to the challenge
and Shawn I could just tell all of your
listeners all across America
we can do this and it's going to take
all of us as the president said many
times we're all in this together but I'm
absolutely convinced with the
cooperation of the American people with
the compassion and care of our health
care workers with the with the full
engagement of American free enterprise
the partnership that with our states all
of our great federal leaders and the
prayers of millions of Americans we can
slow the spread we can protect our most
vulnerable and and we can heal our land
that's our prayer mr. vice president all
hands on deck sir thank you for all
you're doing thank the president we
appreciate it and I'm sorry it went over
time I know you're busy thank you